y nos piden que dibujemos el eje de
reflexión a partir de el cual se refleja
el triángulo abc el triángulo azul de
aquí para obtener el triángulo a prima b
prima se prima que es este triángulo de
color rojo y nos dan una herramienta
para poder dibujar el eje de reflexión
entonces a primera vista parece que los
triángulos solamente están volteados a
partir de algún eje horizontal que hay
por aquí veamos si podemos construir una
línea horizontal que se vea como el eje
de reflexión para eso analicemos qué tan
lejos se encuentra se desee prima vamos
a ver aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 unidades
hacia abajo podemos decir que estos
puntos están separados por seis unidades
así que podemos poner la línea tres
unidades arriba de ese prima y tres
unidades abajo de c veamos si esta línea
horizontal funciona como el eje de
reflexión si aquí podemos ver que se
prima definitivamente es la
a partir de este eje que se encuentra
exactamente a tres unidades debajo de él
y a tres unidades por encima de ese
prima pero veamos si funciona para los
demás y se encuentra a una dos tres
cuatro cinco unidades sobre el eje y a
prima está una dos tres cuatro cinco
unidades debajo de él así que está bien
ahora vamos con el punto ve aquí podemos
ver que se encuentra en de igual a siete
y este eje se encuentra en igual a uno
entonces se encuentra a seis unidades
por encima del eje y ve prima está 6
unidades debajo del eje por lo que no
hay ninguna duda de que este eje de
reflexión que hemos construido funciona
se refleja el triángulo azul es decir el
triángulo abc en el triángulo a prima de
prima de prima nos vemos en otro vídeo